GREAT TO SEE JAKE ALLEN, A
CHRISTIAN DVORAK BACK.
YOU'RE GOING TO GET A
GROUP.
SO I'M SURE WILL
IS BACK IN THE
FOR DALLAS CAN MONTRÉAL.
DVORAK BACK IN THEDS UP AND OETT
ON THE ICE TWICE WITH EYES. PUCE
GOAL
FRONT.
RAFFL STILL ON THE LIKE.
>> COOL.
>> PRETTY COOL.
>> YOU KNOW HE'S A C DRAW.
BACK TO FACE-OFF.
HE GOES SLIDING OUT FURTHER THAN
HE WANTS AND HED AS JAMIE
BENN FIGHTING FOR T ONE-O HIS R.
RADULOV'S DRIVE INTO A
ON THE BENCH., AND THE
HE HOBBLED OFF HALFWAY THROUGH .
PAVELSKI TRIES TO JAM IT IN HIM.
FAKSA, SO YOU HAVE COULD GET
CRAFTY, TRYING TO S SECONDS.
[ CROWD AWAY.
DAUPHIN, ABLE TO GET THAT PUCK.
KEEPS THE PLAYCHECKING SHIFT, PN
COMING IN LATE, KEEPING IT
ALIVE, IT.
SCHUENEMAN FLIPS THE DEFENCE,
OVER THE GLOVE, A HE WENT W OF .
IT'S ANOTHER SHOT THROUGH
SCREEN, THE ICE.
ONE LAST PUSH FROM PAULE AND IT.
BRINGS IT UP TOEY'VE GOT ONE INT
ON THAT LOOSE PUCK.K.
BLOCKER, PRETTY GOOD THERE, JAKE